The joe rogan experience.
What is it about war movies that drive you the most crazy?
The fact that almost everything in them is an accurate,
almost everything.
Biggest thing that drives me fucking crazy is when grenades create a fireball
really?
Well.
Yeah,
cause it happens in every movie.
They throw a grenade and a 55 gallon drum of gasoline explodes and people go
flying backwards and cars flip over.
If you throw a grenade,
it goes pop and it puts some dust up in the air and if you're waiting for the
fireball,
you're going to be there for the rest of your natural life.
It's just not going and they're not that effective.
They're fun.
Don't get me wrong,
but they're not that effective.
I did not know that.
They don't create a fireball.
No,
I've never seen a grenade go off.
Obviously.
I'm sure Jamie can pull one up.
It just goes poof.
It's dust is all it is.
Seen one in a video.
I'm sure for a moment like the momentary explosion there is a flash,
but other than that it's literally just dust flying up in the year.
What?
What is the best military movie that's the most accurate or the most,
the Least Offensive Navy seals starring Charlie Sheen.
Really?
No,
not at all.
Oh,
Jesus Christ fell down.
That fucking guy.
Probably full fooled more people and to come into the seal teams than anybody
else.
Really?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I mean,
these fallen through skylights with MP fives and handlebar mustaches.
You know,
there's snipers calling himself.
God,
I can't see anything.
I'm switching to starlight blasting people through a concrete wall.
They're doing free fall jumps are in submarines.
Like that's an entire 30 year career to do all that shit in 60 minutes.
You take that expectation,
you,
you come to the team,
it's like,
God,
I'm kind of bored right now.
So was that the war areas saying Bang,
Bang,
look at,
I'm going to run boys.
Yep.
I want to make it.
And he's got the,
the,
the requisite,
a scarf around the neck and first off,
one of those.
So what kind of asshole wears a red scarf and an environment where there is no
red.
He's got green utilities on from Vietnam.
When I read,
uh,
Shamal yeah,
this is so hilarious.
So in other words,
you know Charlie now like such a fucking psychotic partier and so apparently
apparently so they came to the buds compound and did a little bit of training
with the guys and I guess there was some bass and breaks and they'd just be
like,
all right,
you guys ready for some more PT?
Oh really?
That makes sense.
I've always see hearing that 18th hand.
But I want to believe it's true in with reversing aging and age related
diseases.
I mean we're,
we're anting are entering into an incredibly strange time for the,
the influence of technology and innovation on human beings,
on our bodies and our brains.
And we're going to have to decide,
you know,
how,
how far you want to go on this ride next stop far Rockaway.
Like when are you getting out?
I lived there.
I lived on the beach there.
I'm going,
well it's,
no,
I don't know.
But you know what I'm saying?
It's like one of those things like where do you get off?
Like when,
where,
where do you go that okay,
that's enough.
You know like with you,
you're deleting Facebook,
you lead to delete Instagram and you go just going to be on mines and that's
enough.
And going other places,
I mean these,
there are alternatives that are getting very big.
Yes.
And and together like what?
Like signal has tens of millions of users.
I don't know what that is.
I've never heard of it.
That's like the encrypted messaging app that,
do you know what?
I don't,
it's open source.
What is it?
Snow is on their advisory board or whatnot.
What is signal?
It's just a messaging APP.
So a message but like a whatsapp or like a Twitter,
whatsapp.
So you have to know the person and then contact them through it.
Yeah,
but we're talking,
we're,
we're considering using the signal protocol for our messaging system cause our
messaging system needs an upgrade.
But all of us together are going to be be able to create sort of like a,
a group of apps that are like sort of a more open freedom supporting privacy
alternative and like,
so it's,
we're not going to solve it by ourselves and
it would be way easier if one of these big companies would just switch gears and
start doing things the right way.
I mean,
we've spent eight years building this.
If one of the big companies,
Google Facebook had just been free and open source,
we would have spent the last seven years building on top of them.
Right.
Because you know,
they already did something cool that they're sharing with everybody.
So it's,
it's actually closed source projects stifle innovation because if you think we
had to reinvent the wheel,
we literally,
we went and built an alternative with much of the similar functionality.
Think about how much further the world would be if everyone was building on top
of more common protocol.
Um,
in terms of like groundbreaking sketch comedy shows though,
like that,
that,
that k k k bit where he had the,
uh,
let me tell you something.
Do you understand?
In the history of sketch,
nobody has premiered a schedule and it came off so hardcore the first night,
it's hot as hell.
She's hard as it comes.
When they ended the shit when,
when we asked why,
why after all these years would you still,
so he was like,
because she's a nigger lover.
I was laughing.
I was like,
that was one of them.
That was one of the joints.
I'm like,
wake up everybody no more sleeping in bed.
No.
From that moment that does show was going to be on the next level of well was he
was free.
It was,
it was so many when we did.
Funny thing,
a lot of things I used to do,
I was a warmup comedian for a Chappelle show.
So whenever you saw Chappelle show episode,
if you'd noticed that whenever I came on screen and I'm not being cocky,
people who go nuts,
they'd be like,
Oh shit.
In the reason was because I was a guy that wanted the audience before Dave came
out.
Ah.
So I knew if I go get the room out at the beginning,
people don't.
People don't even,
they didn't,
nobody knew I was there anything.
If I ripped that at the beginning and then when they see me on the screen it's
going to be like,
it's going to be big horse and,
and,
and that show man.
It was just like,
there was just a lot of things happening to show people like Rick James Sketch
the day we played that during the wraparounds.
Man that should hit so hard.
I was like,
this shit is fucking crazy.
Crazy funny thing people don't know is that comedy central did not like that
sketch
comedy central.
Here's the,
this,
you got a funny comedy central.
They're like sketch and comedy central.
Didn't think Charlie Murphy was funny in it
and I watched,
we ran as shit sick just to let you know the direction when people think I
wasn't shit six times and every time man,
every time you heard Dave say,
I'm Rick James Bitch.
It was gut son.
It was gut side.
Yo,
what did the five figures say to the face?
Wow.
When's the last time you had to sketch was getting kids to spend it in school?
Right out of school.
Take teachers are the five things they say,
bye.
I'm Rick James Bitch.
All right,
Tom,
you suspend for a week.
You add Dave Chappelle.
Go to the fucking time.
Out Room is one of the most iconic sketches of all time.
How wrong was comedy central?
I mean,
not just a little wrong.
A lot along the way,
wrong all the way wrong,
like almost like suicidal and was like,
hmm.
But then it goes to show him.
It goes to show,
you know how you have a vision with something.
You see it.
Everybody may not see it.
Right?
One of the most important things I learned for both of my books,
but chasing scream and lost connection is that these forms of despair,
depression,
anxiety,
addiction,
they are meaningful signals,
right?
They are telling us something.
The fact that they had been rising year after year after year,
that we're now at the point where average white male life expectancy has fallen
in this country for the first time in entire peace time.
History of the United States.
That is a signal that is telling us something and that's because of drug
addiction and overwhelming cause of drug addiction and suicide is,
it's risen to that point.
Are there other factors going on like obesity,
but that the main drivers are a overdose and suicide and pat,
he's telling us something and what we've been doing up to now is we've been
insulting that signal.
We've either been saying depressed people,
addicted people are just weak.
Or We'd been saying,
oh,
it's just a problem in their brain that there are real things going on in their
brains of course.
Um,
or we've been saying,
you know,
it's just craziness and
yeah,
in fact it is largely a response to the way we're living.
Of course,
there are other things going on as well and we can talk about them.
And once you understand that,
you realize there's got to be a deeper response.
And I went to places that had done that,
not just Switzerland.
There's a few of those people that really don't have talent,
but they made the
right friends and they cling on to folks and everybody gets real uncomfortable.
And that was happening.
I think the first time we spoke,
as I had written,
I think about Louis and after Louise and the whole news,
but Louie happened,
you had all this love that piece by the way.
Thank you.
It was so accurate and honest.
Yeah,
it was on Facebook,
which where I did a lot of my best work.
And what you were saying to people that didn't read it after Louis,
a lot of people were rightly criticized and conduct and you know the whole me
too thing.
That's all valid in short,
100% needs to happen.
But then there were people that were like,
you know,
Louie was never funny or Louie was just,
of course he got all these things.
He was a white guy or,
and I'm like,
wait,
what?
And they were like,
well,
he said this word I don't like.
Well look at this joke.
And I'm like,
guys,
a week ago he was a comic genius.
We all agreed on that.
That was a widely held belief.
Now out of nowhere,
he's not that funny.
And,
and these people are tweeting this from parking lots where they're performing
some of these shows in la or,
and like someone's driveway,
you know,
and which is fine.
I do them,
I've no problem with that.
But they're getting on Twitter and,
and,
and knocking Louis from the back of a parking lot where they're doing a show.
But what the reason you gave for why,
well,
because these,
there's,
in any industry,
people are going to get ahead by being agreeable,
by having the right opinions,
by crowd sourcing their opinions,
by taking the temperature of the room and going,
how does everyone feel?
And those people are,
you know,
they're careerist are very good at office politics.
They're very good at having the right friends,
but their contributions are never really important,
are long lasting because they never get great because they don't take any risk.
Because I think greatness is something you have to risk constantly to get to
that level.
So a lot of these people do very well.
They make money,
they're,
they're successful,
but they are careerist and they're looking for comfort.
And so when it was comfortable and safe to attack Louie and to bring Louie down
and to elevate themselves,
they did it.
But they didn't do it when it could have hurt their career a week earlier,
you know?
So to me it was very disingenuous and the fact that more people weren't calling
it out.
And,
and I,
and I made that point where I said the same thing on the other side of people
who styled themselves.
Like,
I'm a free speech warrior.
I'm this anti PC in their whole entire persona is,
is that the need to say the n word?
They're like,
I can't do a joke if the punchline isn't fag.
Like they're like,
we have to.
So those to me are kind of the same people.
And they're the people that are just trying to arrange the world in a way that
allows them to succeed.